[Music]
[Applause]
Medical News a potentially fatal disease
unknown just months ago is spreading so
quickly that doctors now say it's a
national epidemic 90% of the cases have
turned up in New York and six other
cities it is spreading at an alarming
rate
researchers offer little hope for future
victims because no one knows what causes
AIDS or how to cure 722 cases of AIDS
have been reported in New York City
since the beginning of the outbreak
almost half of those diagnosed so far
have died AIDS was once found only among
sexually active gay men but not anymore
[Music]
researchers complain that very little
money has been spent nationwide to
understand it or to combat it one reason
for that they believe is that the
primary at-risk population is gay men
who don't carry a lot of political clout
this epidemic is not going to remain
localized in any one group epidemics
affect people we need funding to
stimulate research to find the cause of
this new disease would you support a
massive government research program
against AIDS I have been supporting it
we have 100 million dollars in the
budget this year the National Academy of
Sciences has issued a very stern warning
on the subject of AIDS the current
effort to describe is woefully
inadequate this report calls for the
government to spend 2 billion dollars a
year on AIDS research and education the
panel urged the use of condoms during
intercourse we hope it will make the
risky situation completely safe but I
don't think this sufficient research to
be certain
he was tall dark and handsome and he had
that name word of rock Hudson's death
spread quickly this morning and friends
and associates rushed to his Beverly
Hills home for the first time today the
government approved prescription sales
of the drug to treat AIDS a Z T is not a
cure a Z T only seems to extend life for
an average nine months we want more
experimental drugs tested and more
people as quickly as possible
people are dying we're caught in the
middle and we don't know what to do
except protest and protest and protest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like you to join us in an act of
activism
[Applause]
Paul Watford Michael Talbot Rodney
Arthur James moon see a quilt made by
Americans across the country was
unfurled he was diagnosed with AIDS five
years ago when he was 13 one of the
first children man to have AIDS at that
time there's a real danger right now
I'm complacency in the in the fight
against AIDS because a lot of people
feel gee I'm not gonna get it because of
HIV virus that I have attained I will
have to retire from the lady officials
that the World Health Organization's say
that 4 million women will die of AIDS by
the year 2000 I found out that I had
been infected with the AIDS virus I
asked the Republican Party to lift the
shroud of silence which has been draped
over the issue of HIV and AIDS these
patients are not to be pitied
none of us want pity we didn't want
compassion we do want to understand me
the scientific advisory panel has
recommended that the Food and Drug
Administration approve a new drug called
the most important advance since AZT
it's a step in the right direction AIDS
patients are living both better and
longer New York which has the highest
number of AIDS patients in the country
has shown a dramatic decrease in the
number of AIDS deaths a 30 percent drop
[Music]
we have a fresh reminder this morning
that the AIDS epidemic is anything but
history a report from the United Nations
says that despite promising new
treatments more than thirty three and a
half million people are now infected
with HIV and that number is expected to
keep climbing despite what you may have
heard I am cured of the AIDS virus we
can now say with some confidence that we
have the scientific basis to bring an
end to this epidemic we're not sure when
that's going to happen but we know it's
possible you could have imagined that
we'd be talking about the real
possibility of an aids-free generation
we've got to keep fighting fight for
every person who needs our help today
but also fight for every person who
didn't live to see this moment keep
fighting for all of them because we can
and this pandemic we can beat this
disease we can win this fight
[Music]
I want to welcome you to this morning's
panel I think you're in for a really
fascinating discussion this is about
ending the epidemic science advances on
AIDS 2013 marks 30 years since
researchers first identified the virus
that causes AIDS and the statistics are
really daunting since the early 1980s
more than 60 million people worldwide
have been infected with HIV some 25
million have died more than 1 million
Americans are currently living with HIV
and each year 50,000 people in the u.s.
are infected 20% of them do not even
know that they have the virus New York
City has the highest number of new HIV
cases in the nation this morning we're
going to be exploring what science is
doing some of the breakthroughs that you
just heard about some of the challenges
that still arise and we're gonna be
putting a face on people who are living
with AIDS what they're experiencing the
group of people that we have assembled
here today are some of the world's
leading experts on HIV our first
panelist was awarded the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine for his discovery
of reverse transcriptase he's the former
president of the Rockefeller University
and the California Institute of
Technology now he's the founder of Cal
immune biotech company he's working to
develop innovative gene therapies for
HIV please welcome David Baltimore
next he was one of the original members
of act up and he's featured in a recent
documentary film about it entitled how
to survive a plague he founded the
treatment action group and AIDS meds
calm and he's spoken out about HIV and
AIDS on CNN Nightline 60 minutes and the
pages of the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal and rolling stone among
others please welcome Peter Staley
she's a pathologist and immunologist who
consulted on some of the first cases of
what came to be known as AIDS as
professor at NYU's School of Medicine
and director of AIDS research at the New
York Veterans Affairs Medical Center's
she's been trying to solve its medical
mysteries ever since please welcome
Susan Zola Posner and he's a professor
of medicine at the University of
California San Francisco and a senior
investigator at the Gladstone Institute
of our ology and immunology he's run
clinical trials on AIDS drugs all over
the world and was named one of Time
Magazine's 100 most influential people
of 2012 please welcome our final
panelist Bob grant so thank you thank
you all for being here and and all of
you for coming out there been promising
breakthroughs in the past year and also
some some setbacks that we're gonna
examine but but I want to start now with
with the beginning and explore some of
your personal experiences during during
those early years when you became
involved in the fight against HIV and
AIDS so Susan to start with start with
you you've been on the frontlines of
this since the beginning I want you to
take us back to 1981 82 and and share
some of your experience about how you
got involved in what that was like so
there was a telephone call that I got in
the summer of 1981 from a dermatologist
at NYU dr. Alvin Friedman keen who said
that he had seen four young men with an
unusual presentation of skin cancer
called Kaposi sarcoma and since I was
running my research lab studying cancer
and also clinical immunology lab at NYU
he asked me if I could look at the
immune function of these four patients
and they all look
and very unusual in terms of the number
of what we call cd4 lymphocytes a type
of white blood cell in in blood some of
these patients had none of these cells
which is this extremely unusual by the
end of 1981 we had about twenty of these
patients and when you do anything in the
lab you have to run controls along with
your experiments and so we were using
blood from people in the lab as our
normal controls and we said well this
isn't right but we need because we'd
realized that all these patients at this
point would young gay man we needed
young gay men healthy as our controls
and so I contacted a physician here in
the city who had primarily gay practice
and we got specimens from 40 of his
healthy patients and we did the same
Studies on them as we did on our
campus's patients and I will never
forget because for me it was the most
dramatic day of the last 32 years in
terms of this epidemic we looked at the
results in the we realized that a third
of these healthy men who had no symptoms
whatsoever looked exactly like the 20
men with Kaposi sarcoma and we knew at
that point that whatever was going on
and we didn't know what was going on but
whatever was going on a third of the gay
population in the city were subjected to
it - it's really an incredibly chilling
moment and my professional life you know
it began in a sense and and has never
stopped since that moment David how did
you get involved in hiv/aids well
actually it goes back to 1970 because I
was then trying to understand how a
cancer inducing virus grows and
discovered that there was a
characteristic enzyme in the virus
particles which copied RNA into DNA
which first of all was was revolutionary
in itself but what it did was to provide
a marker for this class of viruses now
fast-forward to 83 84 and it was using
that as a diagnostic that enabled gallo
and montagnier and others to find the
HIV virus and to provide the explanation
for what Susan described which was the
ability of this virus to wipe out the
cd4 lymphocytes and to put patients in a
totally immunodeficient situation so I
sort of accidentally found myself
involved and then in 86 I was asked to
head the panel for the National Academy
of Sciences to look at our research
response to this I led a group that
asked for a billion dollars a year and
researched a billion dollars a year in
clinical investigations to move this
problem forward and that was many-fold
what was being spent at the time and we
actually found felt a bit that we were
being audacious and asking for it but in
fact within a couple of years we were
spending a billion dollars a year and I
think we can say that today we
understand this virus better than any
other virus on earth because we've put
these really impressive resources behind
understanding it has it actually stopped
the epidemic again we will we will get
to that Bob you were you were involved
from the beginning
well actually compared to the others
panel I would say come in late 1983 I
was a second-year medical student at San
Francisco and Berkeley and I knew I was
interested in social medicine how
medicine could interact with society and
I was looking for a job and and I wanted
to study heart disease among city bus
drivers but there was no work there
somebody said you know study this thing
called gay bowel disease you know
there's there's money coming in to
understand the epidemic and so you know
and there was there was plenty to do and
it was exciting work imagine me at 23
year olds trying to discover a career or
trying to make a career and this was
something where you know they needed all
hands on deck i mean i i'd taken
computer programming classes and so they
said we need you
you needed epidemiologists you needed
biologists and and there was nothing
more exciting than this I mean
retroviruses had just been discovered
and and and and this was one and and I
got paid half time to talk about sex I
mean it doesn't really get better than
that as a 23 year old so it's it really
set the course of my career there have
been times when I've been discouraged
that the next phase of my career I was
told not to focus on AIDS because by the
time I was fully trained the epidemic
would be over and that was 1987 and and
to this day I don't know whether the the
person giving me this advice was
optimistic about the end of AIDS or
pessimistic about how long it was gonna
take for me to be fully trained
but but that is a commitment that I want
to retire after this epidemic is over
and your work is taking you around the
world and we'll get to some of that in a
little bit but Peter I want to bring you
in your your involvement in this came
from a totally different approach you're
the the one non-scientists here here on
the panel tell us your story how you
came to be involved well the virus very
directly brought me into it I arrived in
New York fresh out of college in 1983
and consider myself kind of a case study
in how many gay men were infected in in
82 and 83 and 84 because of the silence
of the epidemic in the in those early
years arriving in New York working on
Wall Street as a bond trader I was very
closeted I certainly wasn't hearing my
mayor or my President or even a
politically active gay community talk
much about hiv/aids I certainly didn't
hear that by 83 upwards of 50% of gay
men were already infected with this
virus they hadn't discovered the virus
yet obviously but that indifference
probably led to my infection and I found
out right after Rock Hudson died in late
85 when the country was in a panic the
tests had just come out earlier that
year and so I was one of the first to to
find out before I became sick and in
that sense I was lucky and one of the
reasons I'm probably here today but I
joined act-up soon after it was born in
early 1987 as I got more and more
frustrated about this silence that
happening around this epidemic well you
as I mentioned earlier you you're
featured prominently in the film how to
survive a plague I saw this film last
week and it's it's incredible I
encourage you all to to watch that but
let's look at a little clip from that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on here and why there are
no treatments out there for people
living with this disease
[Music]
building down that way dr. Anthony
pouches presiding the research
priorities for the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases right
down here because we think we should be
deciding the research priorities because
these are the people who know what's
going on these are dealing with it every
day
[Applause]
that was you being taken down by by the
police at and at the NIH much younger me
yeah I think several of our panelists
we've seen younger versions I'm glad
there's no footage for me now why did
you feel those kind of protests were
were necessary well we were dealing with
first Reagan and then Bush two
administrations that that were came to
power largely based on what was called
the moral majority back then the
predecessor of today's tea party if you
were if you will and these were very
conservative administrations that have
been ignoring hiv/aids for years and and
as dr. Baltimore's a panel pointed out
was spending very little money at the
NIH on AIDS research
we had an FDA that was still probably
the most Iraqi see in DC as far as how
it slowly would it would approve
treatments and the deaths were just
racking up and so we our backs were
against the wall we could either roll
over and all die quietly or we could try
to guilt-trip the country into doing
something about what we were going
through and saving some lives so it was
it was about putting aids on the
national agenda it was about making the
country see what was happening and care
and then forcing the government just
actually starts spending major dollars
on AIDS research and in short order that
money appear and and you have you have a
couple graphs
that you brought one when dealing with
the issue of stigma and who was getting
AIDS Gallup has been asking a gay
related question to the American public
that's very antiquated now in today's
debate but it's the one that they've
been asking the longest and so they
continue to ask it so they can get this
wonderful thirty thirty five-year sweep
and it's basically about sodomy laws
that's why it's very antiquated but it
is do you think homosexual relations
between consenting adults should be
legal or illegal when they first started
asking that in the late 70s the numbers
were about even in the 40s but then as
aids became a story with with Rock
Hudson and a national panic broke out
there was a backlash that started
happening against attitudes against
homosexuals in this country you see that
red line which is the people thinking
that gay sex should be illegal
that started to to really sore and it
hit a peak in early 88 at 57% and then
in 18 months between that 88 number and
the next time they asked it in 89 it had
the biggest move in its history it
dropped 21 percentage points and the
only thing that happened historically in
the AIDS crisis at that moment was act
up bursting onto the scene and we had
the FDA demo that was that was followed
by the quilt AIDS became a huge national
story from that moment on for the next
few years with a series of large
demonstrations and they saw gay men and
lesbians fighting back it just
completely changed their attitudes for a
while against how they viewed us and we
successfully made them they may not have
loved us but they did not like the fact
that the government was ignoring us
while we were dying that hurt their
conscious but let's pull up that funding
slide and and take a look at the the
same timeline this is the NIH AIDS
research budget and how it started with
just a virtually nothing during the
Reagan administration by the time we got
to Bush we were getting up to two or
three hundred million and then during
act ups first five years and after
David's report we kicked out and rose
quickly to a billion and from there it
just climbs now it's over three three
billion a year and those dollars in this
age of austerity those dollars matter
those dollars are what eventually helped
us get the breakthroughs that we have
today and those dollars are ultimately
what we hope can find a cure and a
vaccine
I mean what else do you think
contributed to that rise in funding was
that all the work of act up and and the
advocacy community well no the
scientific community also acted up and
not not so loudly or obviously but used
whatever connections we had within
Washington to impress upon the
government the absolute necessity to do
something and we were all terrified
about how widely this virus would spread
we simply didn't know how widely it was
spread now in Africa in places in Africa
it has spread to 75% of the population
in the United States it hasn't spread
that widely but I find it still amazing
that for all of the information that
everybody has about this virus and about
protecting themselves against infection
we have 50,000 new infections every
single year so it is a problem to the
United States but it's a much bigger
problem on a world scale Susan in those
early years you were doing research what
impacted these protests have have a new
head how did that affect your life well
we were doing the work we went started
our research in 1981 with the first
patients that we saw the problem that we
were having was that we couldn't get
funding so we applied for our first
grant to studies Kaposi sarcoma in 1982
and the people who review these grants
in Washington didn't understand the
impact of what we were seeing so it was
not until 1986 or 1987 on that slide
where the graph is almost still
horizontal that we were able to get our
first grant so you know if if we had had
glasses that could have seen into the
future we could have had a much quicker
start on understanding this disease we
would have had five or six more years of
progress than we've had and
when did the relationship between
activists and scientists mature me was
it was it was it strong from the
beginning that there was an alliance or
there was a transition no we want one of
the things that was very painful for me
to see in the surviving a plague film is
that the activists didn't understand
that there was a very caring a very
active scientific community that was
trying to address the problem and there
there was very little interchange
between that community and our community
that began to change significantly I
would say in the late 1980s when the
activists really came to have a voice at
the NIH in terms of funding
and and priorities for research dollars
so we were probably close to ten years
into the epidemic by the time that the
two groups came together so so with that
research funding there there was some
success some limited success in the late
80s with with AZT then in 1996 a real
breakthrough with with the development
of highly active antiretroviral
treatment or heart Peter how did those
drugs change your life dramatic I
remember coming back from the Vancouver
aids conference where they you know kind
of put a stamp of approval that this was
real and all of us were we had been
through so many ups and downs and
disappointments that there was still
some suspicion like really yeah this is
gonna this is gonna change the map this
much but we all went on those that the
the treatments that had been on those
slides we all started Crixivan and and
to new nucleoside analogs and switched
to them I know I switched the month I
got back from Vancouver and most of my
friends did and within a month all of us
went undetectable which was just
extraordinary and we saw the death rate
in the US and most of the developed
world within two or three years dropped
by 80% so it was it was a game-changer
Bob how do these drugs work and are
there any limitations on that well the
drugs work in combination to block
different stages of the viral life cycle
they block many of them block the enzyme
that Dave Baltimore discovered reverse
transcriptase
they only work in combination and many
of the drugs that like AZT that have
been discovered 1987 which had only
prolonged life for nine months when used
in combination with another class of
drug called protease inhibitors blocking
another part of our life cycle
and another third drug could prolong
life indefinitely so it was it was
amazing to see how incremental
discoveries could eventually lead to the
home run which was prolonged life and
restoration of health and you've done
work to show that these can prevent
transmission not just treat people who
have AIDS
are they good enough to create an
aids-free generation well it that
depends not just on the drugs it depends
on how willing we are to use them and I
mean that by very broadly but yes these
drugs when used and and and sufficiently
to suppress viral the quantity of virus
in the body virtually eliminate
transmission from people who are treated
to their uninfected sexual partners and
more recently we've even discovered that
these drugs can prevent people from
acquiring the virus in the first place a
concept that we call pre exposure
prophylaxis so there's a pill for
preventing acquisition of HIV just
recently discovered and and approved by
the FDA highly effective and we're just
now starting to learn how best to use it
and who wants to use it we're gonna
we're gonna get into that with these
developments for many people HIV has
become a chronic disease in the way that
for some people diabetes is a chronic
disease but there been some some numbers
that are a little concerning the HIV
infection rate went up 22% among gay men
under 25 between 2008 and 2010 how big
an issue Peter is is complacency a sense
that this is no longer such a fatal
disease it is the issue
it depresses me to no end that I mean
while nine while the drugs that came out
in 96 were such a turning point and a
huge victory and saved so many lives it
was a double-edged sword in the sense
that it caused a lot of us to fall down
in fatigue after you know this 15 year
fight and and want to put this as far
behind us as possible and and and that's
sadly especially true for the gay
community in this country and and and in
many countries around the world where
they they want to move on they only want
to talk about gay marriage gay marriage
gay marriage and you'd be shocked to
realize how the gay leadership in this
country with our huge lobbying
organizations and our large foundations
how token their efforts are at this
point on hiv/aids and it's resulting
once again in a rising infection rate so
silence may not be equaling death like
it did in those early years but it is
equaling a whole lot of health care
issues the biggest health crisis facing
gay men today it remains so and we will
see the next generation at their current
infection rates of over two and a half
percent a year these are the
20-somethings right now if those
infection rates maintain fifty percent
of them will become infected by the time
they're 50 why should we continue to
have generation after generation of gay
men in this country in this country
become have a life of dealing with
health care issues and health insurance
issues and popping $25,000 worth of
pills every year we're gonna explore
those issues in our third part in much
more depth but I want to turn now to
talk about some of these breakthroughs
that that people here are
are working on and and see whether the
the strategies are in place whether the
tools are there to to truly end AIDS but
but we also want to hear from voices of
people whose lives have been touched by
the epidemic and so we asked AIDS
activists and some long-term survivors
to reflect on on how things have changed
and and what the science has meant to
them some of the people in this video
are HIV positive some are not but
they're all activists and and they've
all been working to try and and put an
end aids in the early days of AIDS if
you were diagnosed it was a death
sentence I'd see these amazingly
beautiful men reduced to just walking
skeletons 1993 was the worst year that
was the year I lost most of my friends
one hospital visit to one memorial
service to to the to a funeral to a
cremation service to a hospital visit
one after the other after the other
it's hard and if people don't come for
it and I understand why I didn't come
forward for 10 years I lived in absolute
fear and horror that I would be found
out those of us who remember the 1980s
still have the scar emotional scars of
the death and the dying and those scars
may have hardened and healed in some
respects but but they're still there one
day my roommate showed me this lump that
he had on his shoulder and you know this
is about 1981-82 and I went with him to
the doctor and the doctor said you have
AIDS
we didn't really know what to do what to
say and I said to him well can you give
us a referral and he said there are no
referrals you know are you religious
sometimes you would take him to a
hospital they discovered that you had
AIDS they didn't want to touch you I
mean there were times when when people
would die and be put in like black
garbage bags I mean these are the sons
of people that they were treated like
garbage people have a harder time
believing
that you even get HIV a from one active
unprotected sex in my case I think it
was one maybe two you know so with a
friend a good person someone I knew
someone I trusted someone who didn't
know that he had it it took me three
years to confirm that I was in fact HIV
positive because I didn't want to know
none of us wanted to know because if you
were HIV positive it probably meant you
were gonna have AIDS and then die
my boyfriend Michael Gault died of AIDS
Michael was on the protease lotery his
number wasn't called because it wasn't
approved in 93 his number didn't get
picked he died to me that such shows
what the meds did how if you weren't
lucky enough to have your number called
you died and if you were part of the
trial for the protease or lived long
enough to actually be somebody who could
just get it at a pharmacy you started to
live I remember that period where
friends who looked like they were gonna
die suddenly the retroviral drugs
started being available and they went
from being emaciated sick Kaposi's
everything to actually clawing their way
back into some kind of functional mode
so hallelujah that was amazing and
frankly had I not been in that early
clinical trial I might not even be there
today there are so many people who
didn't make it and I was right on that
cusp of you know had I been diagnosed a
little bit earlier I might not have made
it
people died back then so that others can
live today those who live today need to
know the sacrifice the those people who
died made in the 80s and the early 90s
so that their sacrifice wasn't in vain
we want to now turn to to some of the
exciting science that that's going on
looking for the next big big
breakthrough and we're gonna look at
three approaches of vaccines gene
therapy and and drugs I want to start
with with vaccines at a memorable press
conference in 1984 the Secretary of
Health and Human Services Margaret
heckler predicted that an effective AIDS
vaccine would be available within 2
years we're still waiting
David I want to ask you why has it been
so hard to create an effective vaccine
well first of all we always make fun of
that statement of Harvard health
hecklers but she had history on her side
when we discovered that a disease was a
viral disease
we usually knew how to make a vaccine
and vaccines came along pretty quickly
once once we figured out how to make
them and so we have vaccines today for
mumps and measles and smallpox and
chickenpox and polio and what both
whatever so some of us suspected that
this wasn't gonna be true for HIV and
the reason was because HIV is a chronic
disease that the immune system can't
control if the immune system could
control it then we wouldn't have the
problem we have and that one fact led us
to be suspicious that when you tried to
make a vaccine you were gonna discover
that the virus had already figured out
how to be resistant to the vaccine and
that turned out to be true and so this
virus and it's not uniquely true of this
virus but but there are very few lykan
has figured out a whole variety of
fascinating ways I mean from a
scientists point of view it's amazing to
see what's evolved to counter the immune
system to not be sensitive to antibodies
to not be sensitive enough to T cell
immunity so the T cell immunity can
used to protect against it and so we
have been unable to make a vaccine and
we have now seen fairly large-scale
clinical testing of a number of vaccine
candidates at phase three which is when
you really look for efficacy and they
have all largely failed one was partly
successful and we're still trying to
understand exactly why that was true you
know to see whether we can learn
something from that that'll lead us
forward well Susan your work is has been
around vaccines what's your strategy how
are you approaching this difficult virus
well I think it's very important for
people to understand that there are many
different strategies that can be used
for making a vaccine so it's not a
matter of a silver bullet we know how to
make an attack same to polio therefore
we can use the same methodology we can't
they're men five large-scale clinical
trials of vaccines four of them have not
shown efficacy one of them showed
marginal but statistically significant
efficacy I like what you said before
about the fact that the incremental
discoveries lead to the final home run
and incremental discoveries sometimes
are labeled as failures but an
experiment isn't a failure if you learn
something from it and so for instance we
had the failure with vaccine trial a
third large vaccine trial which was
called the step trial the step trial was
a real blow to the field because in that
trial individuals who got the vaccine
were more likely to get infected than
the controls I mean that is the worst
possible after felony you can look
for but we learned something some some
very important things from that trial so
was a failure in terms of it didn't
protect it actually made things worse
but we've learned some very important
things from that vaccine trial things
not to do again you've got learned from
history the the fourth vaccine trial was
the Thai trial was conducted in Thailand
and the results were unbonded in 2000
and published in 2009 and there was 31%
efficacy rate now 31% is not as good as
we want but it was the first signal that
we had that we could prevent AIDS and
that's trial that I was not involved in
the clinical part of it but I've been
very much involved in the follow-up to
it and I there had been a lot of
controversy in the field there still is
a lot of controversy in the field as to
which strategy we should use to make a
vaccine now should we should we use a
killed virus vaccine should we use a
subunit vaccine should we use should we
stimulate the t-cells should we simply
stimulate antibodies etc etc and the
Thai trial indicated that antibodies are
extremely important in prevention and
and that that is something that is
absolutely essential for vaccine what
what are there's a term broadly
neutralizing antibodies this is
something that that you learn from the
Thai trial actually no so to be a little
bit controversial I would say that that
the field of AIDS has become enamored
with these broadly neutralizing
antibodies
antibodies that are isolated from a very
small number of HIV infected individuals
and they are fantastic antibodies they
can stop the infection of most any virus
in very small quantities and the idea
the hope would be that we could and
develop a vaccine that would induce
these broadly neutralizing antibodies
that's that's the hope but I refer to
these antibodies as Michael Jordan
antibodies it's just fantastic
antibodies but I don't think that
there's gonna be a vaccine that's going
to take turn each of one of each of us
into Michael Jordan and in in the the
Thai trial
none of these fabulous broadly
neutralizing antibodies were induced but
we did get some significant protection
which I interpret that certain types of
garden-variety antibodies that
theoretically we can all make may in
fact be sufficient to protect us and so
a lot of the work that I'm doing is to
try and design a vaccine that will
induce antibodies that we can all make
that will protect us instead of trying
to turn everybody in the remnants of
Michael Jordan no as you mentioned there
have been a number of vaccine trials
that have failed trials where where
people who receive the vaccine actually
had higher higher rates of disease Bobby
I want to pull you in and ask you you've
done work around the world when you have
a trial that that fails in that regard
how do you go forward with with getting
people to agree in countries to agree to
do the next trial
they've become that much harder well I
can I think you have to start very early
on and helping people understand the
scientific process you go into these
studies really not knowing what's gonna
work and what's not gonna work and you
do who come up to the plate hoping to
hit a home run I mean I think every
trial that we've done we've done hoping
that this vaccine or this
or whatever we were doing was gonna
completely block transmission but if you
can walk away from that having learned
something as Susan pointed out then
that's a win
and you know I think that we we try to
do as much as we can we certainly need
to do more to to tell people what the
scientific process really is and and and
you know one of the things that I think
that the history that's being told today
about drug development and the role of
communities that needs to be told
worldwide is that is that that drugs and
vaccines succeed when they're developed
collaboratively and when there's input
from broad sectors of the population the
the story that you're hearing is is not
widely known in other parts of the world
I think that most of the people we work
with in Asia Latin America and Africa
still have the impression that drugs
come in a in a postal box already
developed already effective already
ready to go and and that is the way that
antiretroviral drugs came to them they
did not have the experience of having
helping to develop those of the early
disappointments and the eventual success
I think we need to involve people
communities around the world earlier in
the process of vaccine development and
and development of other protect
prevented so that they can see that
sometimes a lot of the time it fails but
sometimes it succeeds and it's only
through failure that you eventually get
the success so I think that you know
essentially mobilization of these
communities authentic inclusion of
people participants as well as the
people who represent them in the
scientific process from day one helps
people understand when things don't go
well it's because you didn't know
whether it was gonna work you didn't
know how to make a vaccine but you have
to try anyway and so when it doesn't
work it isn't it's not so disappointing
because they knew from the beginning
that it was you know what do you see as
the biggest unsolved part of the puzzle
when it comes to to making
effective vaccine we've we've got to
find a way to immunize people so that
they don't have to take an action in
order to protect themselves
that's when public health works that's
how the mumps vaccine the measles
vaccine all of those work we don't even
think about the fact that we're
protecting ourselves because we've taken
our shot and that was in our history and
we've got to find a way to to make the
equivalent thing for HIV and as Susan
said we have these broadly neutralizing
antibodies and using those as a model
for immunization is a very difficult
concept and anybody who's trying to do
that today and there are a number of
people trying to do it knows that it's
it's about as hard scientifically as
anything they've ever undertaken on the
other hand those antibodies are sitting
there we can make them in whatever
quantity we want and more importantly we
can put the genes for those antibodies
into viral vectors these are viruses
that have been gutted and we're gonna
get to that work alright next yeah all
right should I shut up and wait yeah
wait wait just a sec I've never told the
Nobel Prize either before
to be quiet it's really something here
Susan what do you see as the as the
missing piece of the puzzle to reaching
an effective vaccine well I think the
question is whether we can induce
antibodies with a vaccine in a realistic
way in a relatively short period of time
in a reproducible way and in a
reproducible way right I mean we the RV
144 the tie trial was one trial and
16,000 people incredible amounts of
money effort running these vaccine
trials is horrific ly expensive and then
you get a 31% efficacy rate and you say
and a lot of people who say well you
know I don't quite believe this I happen
to believe it but it it's not easy to
reproduce as an experiment with 16,000
people okay and then times change and
products change but one of the points
that I want to make and this refers back
to what David was saying is you know you
get two shots for mumps I think or for
measles right you don't have to come
back in two months later four months
later nine months later twelve months
later to get boosted and boosted and
boosted and the immunity lasts for a
long long period of time the problem
that we're having even in the one
successful trial that we have is that it
required for immunizations over six
months and six months after the last
shot all of your antibodies were gone so
it didn't have the lasting response so
what we need to do the most critical
thing is figure out what the coral it is
of protection okay we I think that a
major part of that is antibodies but
then you have to induce them with one or
two shots and it has to give a response
that lasts for a long period of time
well I want to I want to shift now to
what David was was starting to talk
about not not everyone is working on
vaccines there's the area of gene
therapy can you talk about what Cal
immune what your company is doing how
this approach is is different in novels
actually there are two things that we're
doing one that involves cadmium the
thing I want to started talking about
doesn't okay
it's work that we're doing with the
National Institutes of Health and what
we're trying to do is to design viral
vectors that encode these super
antibodies these Michael Jordan animals
what's a viral vector so a viral vector
is a virus in which we have taken out
the genes that make the virus dangerous
that make it a source of pathology and
we replaced those genetic regions with
something that we want to use in this
case the genes for these super
antibodies so we can design a virus that
encodes really nothing but this antibody
and we can put that into the muscle of a
mouse and we turn the muscle into an
organ to produce antibodies and so we
can actually get phenomenal levels
concentrations of this antibody made in
a mouse in after a single injection and
it lasts the lifetime of the animal and
it protects the animal against HIV
infection for its lifetime we have to do
some tricks to get an HIV infection in
mice but I'll leave that aside and so
we're now taking this to humans I mean
we're going into manufacturing so that
we can try this in humans there's really
no reason why it shouldn't work the
viral vector that we're using has been
tested in humans it does lead to protein
production it's never led to handle body
nobody's tested it so we're we're
actually pretty confident now the
category is another story and I'll leave
that aside okay but this is going to be
going into into humans in within the
next year or 18 months I would say Peter
would you sign up for clinical trial
like that yes if if it were in my case
it would have to be if they test it as
the therapeutic vaccine and but
certainly I would love to not have to
take handfuls of pills twice a day for
the rest of my life and all the side
effects that come along with that
getting my immune system to fight this
virus along with these antivirals or in
replacing these antivirals is what we
call functional cure and it's it's
something I hope to be around to witness
and take you know David you've called
the gene therapy approach a Hail Mary
approach why why go down this Avenue if
it's if it's such a long shot the reason
is because nothing else is working if we
had a standard way of making a vaccine
if Susan can figure out how to make it a
mutagen that will elicit antibodies that
will protect people I'd go out of
business tomorrow because what we're
trying to do has not been ever done on a
large scale in the human population and
so we don't know what we're gonna run
into and I don't want to find out we're
gonna run into unless it's absolutely
necessary
but my judgment is right now it's
absolutely necessary because all the
methods that we have for protecting
against transmission require that
individuals take action every day every
every week and people just don't do that
and so they don't protect themselves in
a solid way over their lifetimes which
is what they have to do and that's what
a vaccine does that's why we're all here
so comfortable these days the the third
approach to trying to knock out HIV is
is looking for a drug drug therapy cure
and you know when you think about
bacterial infections you get pneumonia
you're given an antibiotic and and the
infection is is cured and so the idea is
could drug therapy be used as a way of
wiping out HIV currently that's not the
case and it keeps it at bay but then it
comes going back in in most people if
you stop the drugs why Bob is it so
challenging to try and rid the body of
HIV with with drugs well there are
several challenges you know I think
before we dis the drugs though let's
emphasize that when started early they
restore the immune system to health and
people as nearly as we can tell can have
either normal or near-normal lifespans
these drugs though cannot be stopped as
you mentioned because the virus is still
there waiting in the wings this is a
virus that integrates itself into the
human genetic material so it's a it has
an integration xym that gets the viral
material into the human genome and that
allows for latency it also allows for
persistent infection and a variety of
different cells including a cell that we
call macrophages which exist in the
brain it really exists in all of our
tissues but you know I think we're we're
just now learning that that the drugs
also are not really penetrating as well
into all the tissues of the body as we
had hoped we know that these medications
can lower viral load in the blood to
very very low levels but it doesn't
eliminate them but the drugs are not
quite getting into all of the different
parts that are in
the the part of the intestine the part
of the brain and and it does now look
like there's ongoing viral replication
occurring even when people are taking
combinations of therapy so that's the
bad news the good news is that some of
these new drugs some of the the more
recent therapies do appear to be having
additional benefits in decreasing or
eliminating all signs of our replication
which can be quite subtle you know we're
not talking about viral load anymore but
we're actually talking about measuring
the the intermediate steps that the
virus takes as it replicates and we can
see that the use of some of the newer
classes of drugs is is causing those to
decrease even further and that's good
news if it's it opens up the question
again that that therapy started early
enough and and and using the right
combination could be sufficient to reset
viral replication we also have some very
promising cases I mean we've heard from
a cohort in in France of people starting
therapy very early something like 15
percent of them can eventually go off
therapy and their viral load continues
to be low so it doesn't happen in the
majority but it's 15% that appear to
have some sort of durable ongoing
benefit and we think that that is partly
due to starting therapy very very early
and of course the case that recently
recently was described at the retrovirus
meeting just this last year of an infant
who started therapy within 36 hours of
birth and continued on therapy for more
than a year then was lost to follow-up
came back in and evidence that the virus
is still in that infant is just very
very hard to find and so it looks like
that infant because therapy was started
so early and so intensively
that may have had a markedly altered
course of their infection so we're more
and more optimistic that therapy and
especially using new classes of drugs
could really have a market impact on the
course of infection there's there a
couple - there are a couple of terms
that are thrown around cure versus
functional cure what's what does that
mean
well it's it's actually similar to what
we've been talking about in cancer for a
long time I mean there's in HIV medicine
just as in cancer there's skepticism
that we're ever gonna get rid of every
last cancer cell or every last HIV
infected cell that may not be possible
but does it matter if someone has such
little virus that they can go off
therapy and the virus doesn't come back
it may still be present in one or two
cells or a spur very small number of
cells but if it doesn't rebound if it
doesn't really cause injury to the
immune system then and people are able
to stop therapy then that's a win
and that's what we call a functional
cure and and your work now is looking at
the use of of drugs both pre exposure
and and post exposure what what are you
fine I mean there's some exciting
results from that what do you what have
you found and what are your the next
steps you're doing moving forward well
the the concept really is to use the
same medicines that can prolong life and
infected people to see if they can
prevent the acquisition of infection in
uninfected people so that concept is
sometimes called pre exposure
prophylaxis and the concept is that is
that people can have a hard time
protecting themselves on a day-to-day
basis but they often recognize that
there's something about their lives
which could put themselves at risk for
acquiring HIV and-and-and we now have a
pill that they can take recommended to
be taken on a daily basis
that prevents the acquisition of HIV we
were able to demonstrate that this works
for gay men and trans women other
studies have shown that it works for
heterosexual men and women
as well it does require that people take
a pill every day and and and and and we
know that that is a challenge but it
certainly could be done I mean people
routinely take a pill every day to
prevent heart attacks or strokes in the
form of medicines for blood pressure or
for lowering cholesterol we also know
that pills can be taken every day to
prevent pregnancy so it is feasible for
people to take a pill every day to
protect themselves and this is just
another prevention pill but this one is
for HIV now you know so far only a
minority of people who are offered the
pill say they want it or are willing to
take it every day but it's a significant
minority maybe 25-30 percent and we're
finding as we're able to counsel people
more clearly about the very excellent
benefits that they get from this that
the percentage of people willing and
wanting to do it is increasing what's
the what is the funding picture look
like for funding around drug therapy
drug a drug cure for for HIV is is it
where it needs to be well I think that
just in the last year and a half there's
been new NIH initiatives to fund
research on on a cure inspired in part
by Martin Delany who you know was a key
activist who helped the research
community stay focused on a cure
realizing that therapy the prolongs life
is good but it's not it's not good
enough
eventually we do need a cure and so I
think Martin Delany inspired a group of
scientists to really propose a
collaborative process for looking for a
cure is it enough money no I don't I
don't think it is I think that this
eventually a cure is the way that we can
treat and prevent this disease but I
would also say that that's starting with
the amount of money that they've given
is a good first step because we do need
new concepts and cure research it's
interesting because we we saw with the
the graph how federal dollars
and dramatically change the course of an
illness it's the same thing with cure
research the dollars we spend now will
ultimately lead to a cure I'm convinced
of it but we we have to make that
upfront investment it's very so it's a
it's a it's a debate we need to have
especially when we're getting pushed
back being told that we're in an age of
austerity and can't afford things like
this it's very very frustrating but cure
research is hot these days and it's
something we should be putting more
dollars into and it's a sea change from
as recently as ten years ago
we're both AIDS activists like myself
and researchers all didn't even consider
it in the realm of possibility anymore
kind of had given up hope on an ultimate
cure but with the Berlin patient we have
a person cured of HIV now and we
possibly have a baby that was a curative
early infection the the possibility the
resistance to the idea that it's
possible has fallen by the wayside
everybody thinks it can be done it's
just a matter of time and effort David
the Berlin patient they just wanted to
touch on that briefly a patient who had
cancer had a bone marrow transplant and
was was then free of HIV infection is
there anything to learn from that in
terms of strategies moving forward it's
not an antibody approach it's something
different right
so the antibody approach that I talked
about ISM is a method of protection
against becoming infected but the Berlin
patient is a situation which somebody
who was infected was treated and the
virus was eliminated apparently from his
body you got us keep saying him
apparently because it's very hard to
prove a negative all you can say is that
there has been no evidence of a virus in
that individual and the reason for it
was that the individual was provided
with cells that don't have the receptor
for HIV so for HIV to infect a cell it's
got to see this
surface of that cell and what it sees
among other things is a molecule called
ccr5 and so the Berlin patient was
transfused with the blood of somebody
who doesn't have ccr5 on his cells and
then those cells grew up in the patient
and now the patient has cells which a
resistant HIV infection and the HIV
infection went away so you talk about
Cal immune in in this company kalamu
what we're trying to do is to mimic the
Berlin patient but we're doing it not by
finding people who are naturally
resistant to infection who are very rare
but rather by inducing resistance using
what's called an SI RNA again it's a
gene therapy style of approach in which
we're putting into the patient's blood
cell system a virus that encodes
something that counters that receptor
doesn't know how that receptor to appear
on the surface of the cell and so it
makes the cells resistant to HIV and
we're hoping that that will work and
that's going into clinical trials right
now and the first patients will be
treated next month and we're very
hopeful that we can use that as a way of
effectively curing patients and allowing
them to live the drug free there so
seeing the benefits that the the Berlin
patient had but without the risk of a
bone marrow transplant and right
immunosuppression the whole nine yards
well actually we have to do some things
that are not so terribly different but
we don't have to put in foreign bone
marrow into the patient which you have
to do for the Berlin vision well all of
the breakthroughs we've been discussing
give give hope that there could be an
end to AIDS and and we're gonna get to
that topic now but let's go back and
listen once again to some of the voices
of those who are in the middle of the
fight my hope for those living with HIV
and AIDS is that they all get
antiretrovirals
so they remain healthy so they don't
spread it so they don't often their
children but my real hope is a killer I
want to see that breakthrough happen but
I don't want the lessons that we learned
in the old days to ever be forgotten
the biggest misconception back then was
and still is it'll never happen to me
so it's not the red flag that it was
it's something people have been hearing
out for 30 years so it doesn't have the
resonance that it once did when it was
the new disease of the century you have
enormous scientific accomplishment you
have enormous scientific potential
that's the good news the bad news is we
have tens of millions of people not in
care we have lots and lots and lots of
new infections and in more than 50,000 a
year in the ISIS of America alone which
is unthinkable and unnecessary I think
people think it's gone away but here we
are with still 34 million people HIV
positive in the world and here we are
you know with this extraordinary
opportunity where we can end it I know
we're getting closer and I hear about it
I read about it it's talked about it's
exciting we're getting closer to a cure
it's a worldwide pandemic so there's a
lot of work to do and so the closer we
get it just is years and years of work
ahead and getting whatever breakthroughs
we've got into the hands of everybody
who needs it
I have always gotten out of bed in the
morning because I believed I allowed
myself to believe that we would cure it
if I didn't believe that I would never
get up I said to my mom you know what do
we do if I'm cured
and that you know we move on to the next
thing we we go help help with another
cause you know help of another disease
but it would be an incredible thing to
live to live to that day and to
[Music]
my hope that those of us who are living
with the virus might Sunday have it
eliminated from our bodies and might
hope that someday no one no well the
hiv-positive recent the United Nations
report said the end of AIDS is entirely
feasible and I want to get the take of
of each of you on that is is that is
that feasible is that's something that
we could see in our lifetimes Susan I
don't think we're gonna see it in our
lifetime or in my lifetime I see a lot
of young faces out there and I'm hoping
it will be possible in their lifetime
one of the things that worries me about
the discussion about the end of AIDS is
not that it's not down the road I think
it is but that it is gonna raise
unrealistic expectations much too soon
we're going to have a vaccine in two
years well no I think that people need
to understand that they're gonna be
hills and valleys they're gonna be
successes and failures and it's the
process and it's gonna take us a while
to get there okay it's just you note
that these phrases end of AIDS and
aids-free generation did not really come
from scientists they didn't come really
from the activists that came from the
politicians and they're great that they
are they are obtainable goals we all
believe that but right now they're there
their political statements that aren't
being backed up by the resources that we
need to actually make it happen Bob well
you know I'd like to be the voice of
optimism I I do think that it's feasible
I think that we have we know how to end
this epidemic I think that getting it
done though is is not to be assumed
I think all of us will probably end up
doing a lot of what we like doing and
some things that we don't like doing you
know the scientific community needs to
invest much more in what we call
implementation science you know how best
to use therapies that we already have
it's it's not the kind of science that
is excited you know those of us on this
panel but it's valuable science it's
interesting it requires a new skill set
a new generation of young people to take
this on and I think that that kind of
research really how to implement things
I think making commitments to healthcare
as a right is is it could be one of the
most important legacies of act-up health
care is a right it's not okay to let
friends and family or even strangers die
of a disease that you could treat or you
could invent the treatment for that
principle has not been universally
accepted around the world you know in
practice we do not treat healthcare as a
right and yet I think deep in our hearts
we believe it is because we can't stand
by and watch people die of something
that we know how to treat and and and
really establishing political will to
make health care rights just as
education or other things is one of the
legacies of act-up that that that is
required to really implement what we
know how to do it's gonna take more
money but it's not an unmanageable
amount of money the amount of money we
spend to keep ourselves safe from HIV is
a small fraction of our total security
budgets I mean I think humanity has made
it very clear that we will spend
enormous amounts of money to stay and
feel safe we just need to define safety
from HIV as part of that agenda and
we'll find plenty of money that the
amount of money to fully fund aids
programs around the world is small
compared to what we're spending on other
things David isn't any feasible I don't
think an end is feasible if it requires
action on the part of individuals
to protect themselves because too many
people grow up through adolescents when
they believe that they are immortal and
they still smoke I mean for all of the
years that we have been saying that
smoking is is a death sentence people
still smoke newly emerging gay men still
have sex without protection and so I
think we have to see this as a public
health problem we have to find a way to
protect people so they don't have to
think about their protection and then
maybe we can actually put the genie back
in the box you know even even without a
new tool for eliminating it's there
there are a lot of tools right now that
have changed the face of this pandemic
but I do want to pull up one slide here
that looks at AIDS around around the
world
and and where AIDS is occurring because
it's it's not one pandemic anymore it's
it has a very different face in the
United States to to what it has around
the world and Bob you were talking about
implementation and money for
implementation so that existing tools
can can get out there the majority of
disease in sub-saharan Africa and parts
of Asia is enough being done to
implement what we what we already know
and
and can use to prevent and control AIDS
no no we continue to underfund the
global efforts on the HIV you know I did
estimates of what is required range
between 24 and and and and 35 billion
dollars a year depending on how much of
the existing portfolio you want to
implement my bet is that we're gonna
have to do all of it and do all of it
all the time so I would aim higher the
most we've been able to raise globally
for the the war on AIDS is about 18
billion dollars I think so we're
underfunding it but again not by an
impossible amount I mean we could raise
the additional money by by making this a
focus of human safety dude I don't think
we will eliminate it that way we can
help people there are many people who
would be helped enormously by
availability of drugs today but that's
not gonna put the genie back in the box
and I think we have to think of it that
way and I personally believe that the
discussion about the cure for AIDS is a
good thing because it's focusing people
on thinking about new ways of
approaching the problem and the one
thing that we haven't had enough of is
new thinking and so I am very supportive
of that but I don't believe it's gonna
happen on any kind of short-term scale
Susan well as I said I think it's it's a
long road and I'm very concerned about
unrealistic expectations
Peter I I want to close on something
that relates to you there's a very
powerful moment in the movie how to
survive a plague and I want to show that
and then ask you a question about that
I'm gonna die from this this isn't going
to be cured for years and years and
years and years
you were you were in your 20s when when
you said that do you still think that's
true you know I'll probably get hit by a
bus before before HIV is going to get me
now and that's an amazing thing to be
able to say I'm 52 I'm dealing with
aging issues now joy up to all Joy's
right and so and I think I you know
maybe I'm younger than you are I don't
know but I think I am I'm gonna be
around when they when they get the cure
I agree we have to lower expectations
it's not gonna be within the next five
years cure research is in its infancy
now but it's a hot area and I think it's
gonna I think it's gonna pay off in the
end it took us 15 years to get to the
therapies that are saving my life now it
might take 15 years to get to the cure
but I I should hopefully still be around
then and I just sort of bring things
full circle by by saying that when we
saw her first patients in 1981 they were
dead within three months so we have
lived through an incredible heart during
these last 30 years and now people are
living with ade and facing the problems
of Aging never in my wildest dreams that
I think thirty years ago that that would
ever be a problem so I think we can end
on a very optimistic note about what the
possibilities are and and what they will
continue to become I I think that does
bring us full circle so I I want to
close and thank our panelists David
Baltimore Peter Staley Susan Zola Posner
and and Bob grant that for a really
terrific
our of discussion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]